let me ask you this i i
saw that you back in the day had you had
a relationship with mustard he tried to
sign you yeah
you essentially kind of obviously didn't
go that way
yeah um what's your relationship with
him now
i feel like musters evolved a lot yeah
as far as because i feel like
you know back in the day he had some
issues with some people in the city and
i feel like he's gotten past
a lot of those issues um and any
uh has he tapped in with you so do you
guys i talked to him
i was like they know hard feelings he's
straight
and he's just telling everybody to just
stay out the way [ __ ] like that all
right
i'm like yeah i know that other than
that we cool
i ain't got no problems with him i'm
cool with everybody man i don't be for
nobody
i'm straight hey that's good man yeah
that's how you stay out you know what
i'm saying yeah pretty much
because i figured it out like i was
talking to my brother and people they're
just like
we're starting to think like people just
want to be with you on purpose so you
can go back to jail again and they can
get their little giant
then i started thinking about i'm like
yeah that might be that might be true
right because i wasn't getting out
talking [ __ ] to nobody i mean i talk
[ __ ] all the time but i wasn't just
getting out just talking i started
seeing people come for me i started
seeing people selling me i'm like damn
you would think people would be happy
like
i didn't tell nobody i beat the death
penalty
i put a lot of like i'm the reason a lot
of people feeding their kids
they got on when i was in jail off of my
[ __ ] bro like everyone knows this is not
a secret
it's my [ __ ] but you know i guess people
are unappreciative
and then it's almost like imagine if
like tupac came back in the year 2000
it would just be [ __ ] up for like you
know
ja
rule
saying yeah wait a minute the real one
is here oh yeah you know what i'm saying
nose ring
like imagine if like out of nowhere
tupac just dropped
dropped back to earth in the year 2000
it would have been rough out here for a
lot of people
yeah i don't know if you would have made
it in 2020 you know it's a whole
different world now you're right
it's a different world they put
everything on the internet
everything is like i can't get on live
or none of that every time
i get on live it's on youtube they
snatch everything i do down
they probably had half the songs already
on youtube before they came out
like whatever